[Musique]
Je suis très heureux que nous ayons pu le faire normalement
et je peux voir mes amis
et
mes sœurs et tout le monde et quand je ne suis pas
assis pendant deux trois ans, nous devons vérifier
toutes les paires corona, nous avons une grande
ligne devant le  entrée pour les gens qui
entrent
parce que nous devons voir le laissez-passer et maintenant
nous le
jetons et disons bienvenue à tout le monde
ouais on dirait que ça fait des lustres et
c'est encore un peu effrayant je
garde toujours un masque sur moi de toute façon euh mais
c'est un  soulagement massif parce que
cela fait près de deux ans et
être piégé à l'intérieur ou être restreint à l'
extérieur, c'est juste épuisant
[Musique]
aujourd'hui avec omicron les avantages de la
preuve de la politique de vaccination ne l'
emportent plus sur les coûts
cette politique a très certainement suivi son
cours
si efficace  à minuit ce dimanche
13 février toutes les exigences provinciales en matière de preuve
de vaccination prendront fin
[Musique]
vous